first patreon question this one's for
aosh can we get an update on the aosh
Sleep Chronicles it's not been cured but
it's not as bad and I think not
traveling as much as help oh really I
think the constant travel and like the
hotel room is never really your if you
have trouble sleeping this is always a
different setting than what I'm
comfortable with also now like I'll just
if I need to listen to a podcast to
sleep or something and my wife is next I
used to be like feel bad like getting up
in the middle of the night and then just
kind of like leave it now I just leave
go to the couch throw on a podcast and
then pass out when I pass out or
whatever it's just like whatever it
takes for me to sleep I've just started
doing that's the priority yeah that's
just what it's going to be and she's
very unbored why put your airpod it I
can't because I sleep on my side side so
yeah
yeah how's the couch I love it I love a
couch sleep really I do too love it
always have as long as it's long enough
if I want to lay on my stomach and go
fully whatever a go you can sleep on a
love seat man I know if I sleep on my
side but weirdly if you do like on your
stomach with your head under the pillows
you need a longer that's true that's
true now now do you have good enough
Shades in your living room uh I have a
sleep mask and the shades are lowered
covered baby you need that sleep mask
cuz the living room Shades like yeah
yeah they don't do blackout curtains in
New York you just can't do it like
legally why oh no we have blackouts full
black out Miami we had a full blackout
great we full I think you made that up
but yeah I know there's no whoever made
the curtains in my bedroom lied to me
then yeah I asked for full blackout he's
like you don't get that here no they
just didn't they just didn't want to
give it to I'm going to ask your guy I
need your guy's number I got you the the
you know you can buy your own CS right
the jump from the jump from the jump
from I don't have blackout curtains to
they're
illegal one of the funniest things I've
ever seen I've been told that by two
guys in two different apartments well
one told case and one told me it they
said we that's not allowed they like you
can't get the full blackout here but no
no no that they're just not offering
that to you CU they don't want to pay
for it so the thing is the they you know
I pay for it though not the apartment we
talked to an independent guy that like
does curtains at the apartment
recommended you just like look it up
online though like you know you could
buy it yourself I'm not buying my own
Cur what do I look like a [__] animal
I'm going to buy my own curtains and put
them up myself that's craziness what
kind of curtains buy them and then you
can get somebody to put them up but I
mean it's not like illegal why would you
even think it's illegal did you even
Google what about it make it illegal no
I believe what I'm told by professionals
it's like a carton yeah I'm just so
confused like you I don't know guys what
did you ask them exactly I want total
blackout curtains and then they said
they're like no man you're not getting
those here you can't get those
here and what did you think he meant by
here well based on the fact that we
tried to do it at another apartment I
got a lot of Windows too I get a lot of
light I don't know if that has something
to do with it you know what I mean you
guys might not have as much sunlight
going to your apartment as me but like
America it's illegal in America you
can't have black thought that was New
York City New York City a lot of stupid
rules so you thought that at at some
point in
time the the city council said you know
what the biggest issue in New York it's
not the migration crisis it's not drugs
it's not homelessness it's we can't see
into our
neighbors homes because they have black
I didn't think it was the biggest issue
but I thought New York would do that so
so you think that New York would make it
so that we could look into each other's
homes if there's any city that is more
inclined to make blackouts mandatory
it's a City where everybody looks into
each other's living room then why aren't
they
mandatory riddle me that because you
don't sleep in your living room this is
the real reason why they they said
probably not to do it you just don't
sleep in your living room so you don't
need the blackout whereas bedrooms often
have blackout because you want to be
really I want Total Blackout in your
whole house yeah I want the ability to
do that I don't want him down all the
time yeah promote control will be nice
you know what I mean yeah they'll come
down that's that's it so you were you
were planning on having some couch
sleeps now I am before it was just for
the bedroom but but you have blackouts
in the bedroom no not total not total
room gets dark it's a law bed citizen
right here
boy oh
that's AOS believes that blackout
curtain and guns are both
illegal that you need to get cassetta
set up that blanket to block the thing
in the window do you remember that I
know I was freaking out well if the city
out yeah I know ripped it really worried
that was so I asked for blackout they
gave me wait let me ask you this you get
any light in your your room cuz some
lights I have blackout but light still
gets in oh now spin it no I'm serious
about this hold on so ask the question
ask the question just so I know so I
have blackout curtains in Miami yes it
looked like pitch black every time I
walked in Pitch Black I asked for black
out curtains in New York you still get a
little light through the slivers on the
side and he was like that's blackout all
right guys we going to take a break from
this exclusive patreon clip cuz I got to
tell you about the best pipes in the
building the freeze pipe right here this
is what's going to make sure that you do
not have that burning sensation in your
lungs they got these glycerin Chambers
you're throwing nose in the freezer
you're taking them out you put them back
in this and you are taking rips that are
going to be cool as a cucumber take the
biggest ones that you need the freeze
pipe is the best most elegant and
deliciously cool pieces in the business
and right now you can shop for these
smooth pipes bub bubblers bongs and dab
rigs at everyday great prices by
visiting the free pipe.com and use the
code flagrant for 15% off your entire
order that's the freeze pipe.com use the
code flagrant for 15% off shop today and
start fighting fire with ice now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
you could join the [__] Army at
patreon.com flagrant thank you very much
peace he said to you the sentence that's
a blackout curtain yeah and you
interpreted that as blackout curtains
must be that's not blackout curtain a
real blackout curtain I don't know if
y'all I'm dead ass it looks like it's
not midnight every time you we
know CU we all have them we all have
them in our apartment I don't have them
I've been D yeah because it's it's
possible that the way that the curtains
sit in your apartment there's a space
between the curtain and the window and
the light and tracks on the sides that
block the light out that's what I want
they have that that has nothing to do
with what you're talking about whatever
that takes I want that whatever it takes
200 bucks I had two set it takes opening
and app yeah whatever that a Russian guy
that's what I need yo that's hilarious
so wait you I'm just so so even though
the guy told you it's blackout you said
blackout it's not a blackout well the
curtain being blackout has to do with
the amount of transparency yeah the op
in the in the curtain right so the ones
that have zero transparency they're
fully opaque and no blackout curtain
dude if there's still light peering in
through the sides it's not a blackout
Cur where your confidence on you being
right right now like if you could just
predict it like 100% so here's my wait
would you say that you're fully blacked
out like in in terms of your confidence
black blackout black 100% complete
darkness okay in Europe oh my God we
stay in France a thing comes down like a
[__] garage door and then there's
another curtain it was an automatic
thing it was incredible yeah slept like
a baby I can't get that in New York in
Miami two sets of curtains one goes all
the way down another one goes all the
way you know people do crack in New York
right yeah like legally no crack is
people do crack not legally but you can
get it bro you think mayor I'm not a law
breaker dude what you look like you
think we can look into mayor Adams home
because he has a translucent curtain son
he a crooked [__] he might be
breaking the law too wow you know I mean
who knows bro May Adams he's blackout
transparent or translucent did I use
that opaque and transparent transparent
all the way through transluc it has to
deal with the transparency so was that
right technically right yeah but also
translucency no it's transparency that's
the amount of light l in that yeah so
the amount of something that's
translucent light passes through right
Luma yeah translucent I think give me
that dum look gets through opaque no
like gets through but when I said
transparent did I say the right word
I'll give you points for transparent I
think that knew I think that satisfies
yeah I think you said translucency I
would also give that to you I think both
of them could work in that setting I
think I would give it to you yeah I
think you're right I think you're right
then I'm right okay I think you're right
that I'm thank you dude I appreciate go
okay listen I I I don't think that
you're willing to wiggle on this I'm not
and I honestly I don't know how you're
going to sleep tonight yeah I'm going to
wiggle for you okay I I don't think that
we have blackout curtains in anywhere
not for real not for Reales I do not
think for anyone watching moment these
lights are actually from the Sun yeah
yeah we have a giant Skylight that is is
blasting light on us cuz it's it's so
bright in here it is illegal to have
prep well there's no windows in there's
it is 100% illegal to have privacy in
New York City it's illegal to have what
privacy well that's not true you know
what I mean you can get curtains they
just don't fully block out all the light
that's all I'm
saying or blackout curtains I think they
just installed them wrong and they like
are they roll do they slide or they
automatically roll down ah slide well
you got the
chain wait yes you just have a little
gap between the window and the Cur yeah
yeah yeah and I want no they just
installed it that has nothing to do with
the curtain that has to do with the
installation they installed your
curtains wrong and he didn't want to fix
it and he's like this's blackout so I've
been that's exactly what or is it down
he said hey is that curtain blackout he
goes yeah that curtain's blackout but
you need the Sid tracks in order to get
no light coming I'm pretty sure he's
like yeah but there light com Side
Tracks whatever that is he just needs
that yeah but you have blackout curtain
you do have blackout curtains if no
light gets through except for they're
100% opaque if you shine a flashlight on
one side you don't see these are
blackout curtains blackout curtains yeah
yeah my sh is not like that but it is if
you if you shine a light it wouldn't get
through but I hate the light coming
through the sides yeah but that has
nothing toght that is the well then get
do you not get what the [__] is going on
you get what I'm saying though yeah no
[__] I get what light com sleep sucks I
don't know that you do I have it in my
apartment light comes through in between
you got a blackout curtain yes he do
this guy dude it's not he not a total
blackout if this is like this you can
see light around it dude my hand still
blocking out all the light but there's
light around it so the hand is made out
of blackout material that's a blackout
hand can you take your hand
slap I'm a th% right not really you
don't have black aable windows that my
what he meant no that's what I mean to
tell you this is what now you understand
your windows the way that they're
designed are very hard to black out
because the only way that you can insert
the curtain there's going to be a gap so
what you could do is you could have a
curtain that's on the outside and covers
everything but they haven't inserted
those because they look ugly they
probably want to hide them and have it
look more elegant you live in a luxury
building right so you now you're getting
it a little more yeah so you have
blackout curtains you just have a window
that has gaps due to the building want
to look more luxurious and that doesn't
work for you because obviously you want
it to be more dark yeah but you might be
able to get those uh those little
spacers to block it thanks for
clarifying boy son that's clarifying
that was fun I know that was tough for
you cuz your building is poor in godamn
bro no I knew when we talk about the
entire time why didn't you clarify I
said they installed your curtains wrong
all right whatever all right list that
was so fun this actually is right that's
not
right right you see what I'm saying it's
not that they installed it wrong my
building just won't allow it no no no no
no no my building didn't do it because
it doesn't look nice or whatever the
building doesn't
want they were more concerned with I was
trying to truncate my words yeah he's
bad on Mike bad on
M okay I know a lot this is from Eric
honig uh I know a lot of what a last
name
I know a lot of us probably how did you
say that how you say I don't even feel
comfortable saying it come on Alex how
do you say it's a fantastic insult no
that's fine I be calling women that all
the
time dick I know a lot can I say that
can I that I can't say it's it's really
dice I know a lot of us probably walk
around unsure about our life goals path
when's the last time any of you were
unsure about your path and what did did
y'all do to overcome that
uncertainty uh last time I was unsecure
about my path was when I was halfway
through your last name
and uh I decided to just pronounce it
and now I'm regretting it uh you imagine
the teacher just saying to say his name
every single day there's no way around
it right yeah that's
tough um Eric H [__] ho dick I know A
lot's probably walk around unsure about
our life goes path when's the last time
you're unsure about your path
huh that's interesting um I I feel like
I'm unsure about my path with specific
things still yeah right like family
stuff it's like all right like what is
my family going to be like how do I you
could join the [__] Army at
patreon.com flagrant thank you very much
peace